Not everyone makes it out of The Walking Dead
alive: the title of the popular zombie drama
could tell you that.
But the most recent episode, the penultimate
installment of season 9, featured some especially
grisly deaths that left viewers shocked.
Spoilers ahead!
Episode 15 of Season 9, "The Calm Before,"
revealed that the Whisperers and their leader
Alpha killed 10 characters by decapitation,
then stuck their heads on spikes and organized
them in a row.
"If the alpha doesn't assert herself, then
there's chaos."
This is exceptionally brutal stuff, even for
The Walking Dead, but the three murders that
drew more gasps from viewers than the others
were those of Tara, Henry, and Enid.
Both because their deaths proved just how
ruthless Alpha really is, and because those
characters don't die in the original version
of this storyline as seen in The Walking Dead
comics, Ezekiel and Rosita did.
After the episode aired, The Walking Dead
director and co-executive producer Greg Nicotero
opened up to The Hollywood Reporter about
the decision to kill Tara, Henry, and Enid
and the choice to deviate from the comic book
source material, saying,
"When we break the story, and when the writers
are in the writers room, we don't always know
when an event is coming.
A lot of times, we'll find out at the very
beginning of the season where some of the
landmarks are.
But we had no idea who it was going to be
or when it was going to be until probably
two or three episodes before we shot."
Nicotero says that the deaths felt "random
and uncontrollable," because Alpha didn't
choose to kill people based on any personal
vendetta against them: she killed to kill,
to send a message to the people of Alexandria,
the Hilltop, the Kingdom, the Sanctuary, and
Oceanside.
Nicotero continued,
"First of all, the deaths are at the hands
of a human being instead of walkers, so that
immediately makes it different…
You're constantly reminded that man's inhumanity
toward man is the most horrific thing that
can occur.
There's a real brutality to it."
Nicotero revealed that the creative team had
to think about how the deaths in this episode
would affect other characters, and that pushed
them to pick Tara, Henry, and Enid.
As he explained, there is a "very specific
reason to lose" Henry due to his relationship
with his adoptive parents Carol and Ezekiel,
as well as with Daryl Dixon.
As far as Tara is concerned, her growing power
at the Hilltop influenced the decision to
kill her off.
And in a somewhat similar vein, Enid's developing
relationship with Alden was also a motivating
factor.
The critical consensus regarding the brutal
episode has been positive, with Den of Geek
calling "The Calm Before" quote, a "stellar
exercise in taking a television show and making
it look like an event."
CBR called it "easily one of the best episodes
of what's become one of The Walking Dead's
best seasons" thanks to the heads-on-spikes
sequence, which is bound to impact the future
of the show in a massive way.
Meanwhile, Nicotero commended Alpha actress
Samantha Morton on her chilling performance
in the episode, telling the Hollywood Reporter,
"Samantha has done such an amazing job this
season.
She so embodies everything that the show needs
and wants."
Though these deaths will likely leave a hole
in the hearts of many Walking Dead loyals,
they do help to thin the very thick cast of
a series that isn't going anywhere any time
soon.
AMC has already ordered a 10th season of the
show, with CEO Josh Sapan saying in September
2018 that the network plans to keep the Walking
Dead IP alive for another decade through all
sorts of media, from the flagship series to
spin-off shows to films and additional comic
book issues.
Cutting down the number of characters on screen
is a necessary evil, as it will allow the
show to continue refining its focus moving
forward.
We know it's difficult to say goodbye to characters,
some of whom have been around for years, but
perhaps these 10 new Walking Dead victims
had to fall so their fellow apocalypse survivors
could flourish.